you
hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played on March 9
1957 this is the first of two games from
an exhibition match played between these
two on the white end the doctor Mac
survey he studied mathematics at the
University of Amsterdam taught
mathematics and earned his doctorate in
the subject in 1926 less than a decade
later he would become the fifth world
champion his opponent the young highly
talented Bobby Fischer this was a
surprise to me but yeah March 9 1957 was
when Fisher turned 14 and this
exhibition match was after that famous
game of the century and if you're
wondering what type of influence this
mini exhibition match against Dave the
fifth world champion has on a young mind
well Fischer later that year in 1957
would become the youngest US Champion
ever so surprising to see how quickly
things go south in this particular game
especially when you consider the type of
opening we're working with a Queens
gambit declined exchange variation
Bishop g5 is noted as the positional
line hitting some more moves in here
Bishop b4 III and a question to the
bishop the pin is maintained
one other note you may find interesting
March 9 1957 was when Game three of the
World Chess Championship took place smee
slob the Challenger vs. the champ Bob
Vinick that was the match Smith Slav
wrestled the crown away from Botvinnik
anyhow from here Fischer now strikes at
White's Center and creates a path for
the Queen
to put some pressure on the c3 point
Bishop d3 this is a nice diagonal
watching over F or a nice improving move
by the night at some stage once the pin
is resolved an additional reason to go
to d3
well h6 has been played which means g6
is a little bit weak not a whole but
weakened and so why not stare at that
point from here some pressure on white
Center and this pressure on whites Queen
Knight is having an influence on White's
King night now
nighty - there's two ways you could go
ahead and support d4 Knight e2 in the
game a couple of reasons behind this one
you stay clear of any annoying pin that
could be broken with f3 and another well
you're supporting c3 so as an example if
the knight goes to f3 it's not there
securing c3y could maybe feel some
pressure like this with this
continuation c4 Queen a5 could be a
little bit uncomfortable coping with the
pressure on c3 so in the game it's
nighty to is connecting Knights capture
on d4
and I like the decision here to capture
with the epon if you stare at a computer
evaluation they'll say you know go ahead
flip a coin it doesn't matter evaluation
around the same but I like the decision
to take with the pawn create a RAM
structure and the other reason I like it
is because White has now the potential
to maybe put additional pressure on d5
or d5 can be a sore spot in blacks camp
why do I say this
well with the night on e 2 it's not long
off from coordinating well with the
other night converging on d5 and d5 you
know this knight on f6 is not the most
reliable defender with this pressure on
the knight the bishops ready to knock
out not just one but two key defenders
of this point continuing both Kings are
tucked away Bishop e6 move 11 this is a
tiny step in the wrong direction Bishop
e6 computer suggests go ahead break the
pin with Bishop e7 this is a move
Fischer plays in the game but just one
move later what is the issue with Bishop
to e6 it's not some losing move but the
issue is related to well it's accessible
to multiple white pieces not only the
knight but also the rook when you look
at what White's next plan is here Bishop
c2 this starts to be a problem having
the bishop on e6 Bishop c2 is preparing
a very nice battery where the Queen is
the leader and checkmate is just a
moment away now these typical eliminate
the defenders sweep into h7 stuff bishop
on e6 Knight f4 this can be a big
problem staring at the weak squared g6
pressure on e6 okay in the game Bishop
e7
Knight f4 and Queen to b6 now this last
move by Fischer is looking to put some
pressure on d4 b2 but this is a losing
move there's no recovering after black's
13th move here a better move is to
secure the e6 square Queen to d7 is one
of the suggestions by the engine
another is to maybe move the bishop to
g4 in this game however its Queen to b6
and so this becomes a big problem and I
have a pop quiz for you what did the
doctor play next feel free to pause the
video okay here we go
winning continuation basically there's a
lot of forced moves here first we take
out the knight eliminate the night and
then go Queen d3 move order is
especially important if you were excited
about playing this first with the threat
of taking here and then mate the timing
is off because of night before Black is
their first eliminating this strong
light square bishop so first in the game
you take the knight only then play to d3
and how do you defend against Queen here
because this Bishop is on e6 the move g6
is not a good move because this pawn is
now overloaded white would be able to
take the bishop and then crash through
white is winning
so black has to prepare to run black
moves the rook and is prepared to simply
bolt to f8 first rook a to e1
Knight B 4
Queen h7 check King f8 and a very nice
move here
a three what's the what's the idea here
you're chasing away the night from
fulfilling a very important role in the
game it's Knight takes Bishop one more
pop quiz we're just two moves out from
this one and well what did the doctor
play next feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
Knight C takes d5 it seems like this is
defended enough but it is not what's the
issue well the king is close to being
mated if the King doesn't have these two
squares Queen h8 is mate so if Bishop
takes Knight here game over
and
if ruck takes knight the move played in
the game we now take the rook
so we're threatening mate now that this
square is covered and the queen is under
fire if you take the knight clean h8
mate and what else is black to do the
Queen is under fire and if the Queen
moves once more
Queen h8 is may after Knight takes d5
here fissure resigns there's just no way
forward the computer suggested g6 just
take the Queen and you're winning from
here you can smash through take that
bishop and mop mop up everything I think
you're gonna win some more soon enough
so this was one minor issue that earlier
decision to put the bishop on e6 in
general placing a piece or a minor piece
on a half-open file or an open file in
this case you're certainly going to be
subjected to some pressure these kind of
exchange sacrifices are present and you
know well in this particular case 92
made the Bishop e6 move you know not
such a good idea it's too accessible to
not only the major pieces but the knight
as well so just a 20 mover the doctor
was not a fan of gifting anything to
Fisher in this game but anyhow as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below I
hope you enjoyed it in maybe even took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
you